[Music]
I want to change I know I need to change
I just I don't have the the path forward
out of my head and I I I I feel
trapped millions and millions and
millions of people live like Eric this
is
America this is
us let's go to Eric is dude right down
the street in Nashville Tennessee what's
up Eric hey Dr John how's it going I get
9 to 13 minutes with a caller right and
they lay out the problem and we work out
an instant solution here's something you
got to do or go try and the thing on my
show is I don't ever know what happens
this is different this is I'm going to
walk with somebody for 90 days and what
I'm going to do is I'm going to check in
with them every 30 days I'm going to
give them some homework assignments and
then we're going to see where we land at
the end what's up
man yeah hey I have a question
uh I'm anxious about being a newly
married husband and hoping to soon be
father I'm suffering with extreme
amounts of anxiety from my past how can
I learn to forgive myself paint me the
full picture
here 2004 my mom suffered from an
extreme car accident that um was really
the first point in my life that I could
remember really being introduced to
anxiety it was a Saturday morning I was
around 12 13 years old and I just
remember hearing like a helic opter but
it was so low that it was literally
shaking our two-story house that
helicopter was my mom had just been in a
T-bone accident they had to land a
helicopter on the road to life fter the
next thing that we were told was hey she
made it through surgery she had to get a
ton of plates in her neck and her
vertebrae and her spine from then on I
started trying to solve for anxiety uh
without Little Help from my parents as
they were doing all they could to to go
through you know her physical damage and
healing process and so I was kind of
left out onto my own and I ended up
going to public high school for the
first time and really got introduced to
everything from girls to rock and roll
to sports I at age of 19 became an
alcoholic alcohol allowed me to numb out
the the internal pain that I was having
where I realized I had to start putting
in more alcohol to numb the things I was
going through and it got to the point
I'm blacking out 3 four nights a week
for a couple years years I made a lot of
mistakes along the way and it led me
down a really really deep and dark path
when you say deep and dark path what
does that
mean I made the decision to have sex for
the first time and okay growing up to
your point that was something that was
instructed to me that I was supposed to
wait until marriage and and that person
unfortunately uh cheated on me severely
to the point where we were seniors in
high school that I found a sex tape she
had created uh with her college
counselor and it absolutely devast at me
because at that point that caused an
even another layer of extreme anxiety
and not feeling
safe so I think one of the big picture
challenges we have in this culture is we
often Define our values by a series of
things we don't do right I don't smoke I
don't lie I don't have sex before
married I don't do these things instead
of my values are based in here's who I
am here's who I'm becoming here's who I
want to be when you do lie your identity
stretches right your values stretch
that's what repentance is for that's
what saying I'm sorry is for that's what
confession is for but if your values are
based in a series of things I don't do
this thing and that's my value I don't
have sex before marriage and then you do
you're
done you're done you have nowhere you
have nowhere to come back from how
honest can I be with
you that the most honest you can be I I
really love your opinions you won't love
these listening to you talk about
yourself is as though you are describing
to me a movie that you
saw not an experience that you've been
through so there's a very
detached way you live your own life
track with me okay all right you got
annoyed as a 14 or 15-year-old that Mom
couldn't do XYZ you were the loneliest
kid on planet
Earth dropped in the middle
of
the hell that is high school you had
been told that the most precious thing
in your life was your virginity and you
gave it to somebody that you loved and
cared about and that blew up on you and
then you made whatever decisions you
made as an 19 20 21y old who was really
struggling to Anchor into
anything alcohol made that go away
that's the beautiful thing about alcohol
it works until it kills you and when you
as a 31-year-old reflect on that and you
reflect on the idea of having a
kid you begin to distill down between
what's wrong with me they're not going
to like me I've got fear I'm scared and
underneath all of that tell me if this
sentence resonates with you at the end
of the day there is a ticker tape
running inside your chest that says Eric
is worthless true or
false true that's the soil this nonsense
has grown out
of and in until you address that core
lie cuz you're
not till you stop holding surviving
childhood versions of
yourself until you can forgive
26-year-old Eric for lying about a thing
that was really important or not telling
your parents the whole truth until you
can let 31-year-old Eric be a grown man
with his own
family until you get
there deal with that core I'm not
worthless man I'm actually a pretty good
guy guy that's hung in there your body
is going to continue to try to get your
attention over and over and over again
are you in on dealing with
that you can't think your way to
that you're gonna have to do different
things are you in on
that 100% because I I've tried the route
you just described and I I know it
doesn't
work so here's what I'm going to do I'm
going to give you some action steps I
want you to commit for 30 days you got a
pin yep I want you to write a timeline
from the earliest memories till 30 years
old the good stuff the bad stuff the
scary stuff those we're going for core
memories I want you to commit to taking
a 30 to 45 minute walk every single day
and if you're a real gangster no
headphones just go for a walk I want you
to commit to SOS skin on skin contact
four times a day have her put her hand
on your face have her hold your the back
of your neck and I'm talking like 30
seconds to a minute got to hold it until
it's
weird I want you to really aim for 7 7
and 1/2 hours of sleep an hour before
bed turn the TV off turn the screens off
and for 2 weeks or so that's going to be
hell for you no news for 30 days none
okay it's going to be weird maybe it is
I I say that is it going to be weird uh
yeah because it breaks my current
routine if I usually read the news or
flip through social media until I fall
asleep but I'm I'm willing to do it oh
my gosh that's like setting your face on
fire and wondering why it's hot yes but
I want you to find somebody who's your
age or 5 to 10 years older and I want
you to invite them to coffee and I want
you to at Coffee say man I've just been
struggling a lot I'm newly married
trying to figure out life or thinking
about starting a family all right
brother it's been an honor to talk to
you we'll catch back up soon thanks Dr
John you got it that's a young man who
either has
done some dark stuff he's done some
stuff that hurt people or he's a young
man who has been trained over a long
period of time to hate himself to not
like the guy he sees in the mirror so
one of the main themes of the homework
assignments I gave Eric is just trying
to get him to turn the noise inside his
own head down and for most of us that's
a terrifying place to be because there's
nowhere to hide this is my first video
Journal I really actually have not slept
very well in the first four nights since
doing the no screens no news I have like
felt internally like physiologically the
need to want to reach up and grab my
phone at night to help go to sleep and I
can't I definitely wish that solving
anxiety and Trauma was as simple as
walking outside for 30 to 45 minutes a
day you're like wow this isn't really
life-changing stuff I haven't been doing
it with any headphones of podcasting and
overall I feel like that's just started
to help my mind calm down having that
Clarity of just not not feeling like I
have a thousand thoughts always going
through my mind you know I really have
had not a lot of opportunities to
connect with someone my age because I
don't have kids and a lot of people that
are in their you know young 30s and are
married usually have a couple kids by
now especially being you know in
Nashville in the South everything's
going great so far again okay I think
that was a really heavy
statement and it was quick I'm really
lonely like I don't have anybody my age
because they've got this this this and
this and then instantly but everything's
going really
great yeah we'll
[Music]
see just have a SE all
right tell me when I'm in the right
place place I feel like an observer cuz
so much of the work is just internal
work for him he's very open about his
journey with anxiety my hopes are just
continuing with that process and taking
the challenges even if some of them feel
like I'm walking 30 minutes a day what's
that going to do just the trust the
process thing of moving through it and
seeing what happens there we go are we
rolling
good
so tell me what you've experienced the
last 30 days both the good stuff and the
bad stuff tell me about it I think my
experience uh with kind of these 30-day
small tasks have just been okay like
surely he's going to ask me to do
something harder than going outside for
30 minutes a day and what I really
realized it was I would start to
encounter other stressful situations uh
maybe through work or just life I felt
like I had more capacity to take on uh
life and I also had just a lot more
clearer thoughts I didn't have as much
uh you know thoughts running around in
my head of what was going on so when I
talk about that weight coming off that's
kind of what I'm speaking to like the
news thing feels like Ace of Spades I'm
good for you know the rest of forever
like I've physically seen that change
but it's been some of these other little
things of I've just been a little bit
frustrated to be honest of like what's
the next thing surely it's going to be
harder surely it's more complex than
this okay my goal over 30 days was a to
give you a a tiny little thing that you
could accomplish right but bigger than
that I wanted to turn down the voices
that consume 24 hours of your day every
single day all the time cuz then you got
to listen to that only voice that's left
which is the voice of Eric so it felt
like that first 4 days 5 days you were
like I will be the best actor that
you've ever seen I will knock this thing
out of the park I'm going to do all
these things in order but if I'm honest
I see a guy who's just trying to get
tasks done which is often a distance
it's a way to distance yourself from
yourself what do you think about
Eric I don't even know how to answer
that question and and that's why I'm so
I don't even I just I don't have a and I
don't know what that disconnect is I'm
just being you know cards on the table I
don't know I don't I don't know
there was a moment
when you talked about I don't have
anybody and then the next sentence was
but my life's great and I'm going and it
was just this quick little drive by of a
window where we saw a really lonely guy
how'd that happen it's a good question
and when I was doing the you know
timeline you asked me to put together of
core memories like there were actually
times where I just wrote feeling alone
in these different seasons of feeling
feeling like I don't know how to connect
of feeling like the only way I know how
to connect is through hitting a home run
on the baseball field through being in
this rock band through you know being
this super involved guy through being
this workaholic and making friends and
people happy of like I have always
longed to connect with the people I love
most and I I to be honest feel like I
never have in a true way cuz I always
had to do this performance thing and so
I don't think that's it Eric I don't
think that's it I I think you don't
connect cuz you don't like Eric
but as long as that ticker tape
underneath the movie that is your life
says I suck I'm not good I don't have
any value I'm not worth anything I'm not
worth anything no I agree I just I I
don't have the the path forward out of
my head like I I I struggle with that of
like I want to change I know I need to
change and Beyond just doing better
being a more good and more bad like
that's the only path that's like in my
head and I I I I feel trapped Emily how
does it make you feel hearing Eric talk
about himself like that I mean I think
the most obvious answer is it's like
that's a huge bomber because I see
something so different It Feels So
contrary to my experience and my
knowledge and every single person that
meets him and is like oh my gosh like
you're wonderful or like you've taught
me this or you've shown me love in this
way so probably a combination of intense
emotions
so before anything good can happen he
doesn't have to fall in love with
himself right out of the gate right that
takes a long time to turn the corner um
he doesn't even have to like himself out
of the gate Eric has to believe he's
worth being
well ultimately my goal for you my dream
for you and it's going to sound insane
my dream for you is peace because here's
what's going to happen uh you'll have a
kid and there will be a complication or
mom's going to get cancer at some point
mom will get sick at some point life
will happen right and so it doesn't
inoculate you from those things but it
does give you a foundation that you've
never experienced before so that you can
be whole when those things hit so for
whatever it's worth I'm proud of you up
to this point it's
awesome I'm going to go back to the
things I asked you to do last time so I
want you to continue with walking every
day I don't want you keep the skin- to
skin contact obviously keep uh sleeping
I think you're a if you turn the
news back on but knock your lights out I
think that'd be stupid to do all right
here you go here's your new assignments
I want you to take that dude out for
lunch again it's going to be real easy
for you all to roll back into hey what's
up bro colleagues y'all got to go to
lunch again okay tell me about your
family once a week you've got to have
somebody over to your house you and your
wife and you have to have at least one
laundry back Basket in the living room
with stuff in it this isn't a Pinterest
this is just having people in our house
yall are going first I want you to find
a picture of you when you were in
elementary school a picture of you in
high school and a picture of you in
college and you have to write each one
of those Erics a love letter telling
them how much you love them sorry for
the hell they went through and how proud
you are of
them I want you to write your parents a
letter and don't send it God help if you
don't send it but I want you to be
honest all of it but there's going to be
two parts to it part one is going to be
here's what y'all did
negative and you're going to have to
write another part of that letter is and
thank you for because I think Healthy
Living is both and almost all the time
all right my brother well
congratulations stay in school don't do
drugs all that stuff and uh we'll catch
up soon all
right sounds good thank you Dr John all
right ma'am how we feel that went
thought this call was a lot better
mission accomplished I felt a lot less
stressed I felt like I just spoke more
honestly about the situations that be
and I just feel a lot less anxious than
I did after the last call man I got to
give him props I didn't think he was
going to do any of this stuff I thought
no he did it so man that's that's that's
mad love mad love there dude mad respect
I'm interested to see how the next 30
days goes day 32 video Journal coming at
you day 34 what's up day 42 day 44 51
days into um this 90day period and
working on living an anxiety-free life I
have the first uh friend coming over to
the house tonight for dinner my wife
makes these amazing things on Etsy uh it
is absolutely huge it takes up the
entire kitchen living room of our space
this is definitely the biggest one thing
I could leave out so we'll see how it
goes reflec on just the experience of
going through and writing the letter to
my parents of the things I'm grateful
for the things that I love about them
but also sharing the disappointments the
pain and it really gives me a lot of
gratitude reflecting on the things they
have done positively especially through
the context of seeing how they were
brought up and what examples were set I
would love to have you know uh an
improved relationship and there's still
time left on the
clock
[Music]
take
three how are you guys man it's great to
see you both I'm always excited to have
my wife with me but now I get a little
bit of a a little bit of Spotlight off
me have another another person in the
gauntlet with me so looking forward to
it um Emily how have you experienced him
same nothing's changed less anxious more
annoying how have you experienced him in
the last couple of months there's
certainly more awareness of oh my gosh
I'm experiencing anxiety right now not
that he's verbalizing it but it's more
like a quick pivot I could see him
spinning a little bit more getting more
anxious or more tense but then almost
see that like switch to when he comes
into the kitchen he's super present with
me not bringing the stress intense but
like leaving it at work you know this
Eric but we um your wife and I met just
to catch up and I cannot I Can't
Describe to you how Illuminating and
awesome that was the reason it was so
great
is how wrong I was on some things I had
fallen under the spell of Eric in such a
profound way I also came to believe that
you had some deep ugly darkness in you
that wasn't worthy of being loved and I
was trying to find it and after meeting
with her I don't know that it's there I
actually think you're a pretty
remarkable guy one of my favorite things
in these in these interactions is to be
wrong it's one of my favorite things
because now we have a whole new
direction right what what are the things
that if you look back over 60 90 60 days
now you're like dude this guy's full of
crap this is stupid like what am I doing
and I know you've had those like like
what are what are those yeah sure so I I
don't think there's any specific actual
like steps that you've asked me to do
there just been a little bit of all
right I'm ready to kind of get on
where's the hard part where's you know
where's the actual like challenge have
you ever seen the movie Karate Kid Pat
Marita who's Mr Miyagi starts training
him in karate and he sells him wax all
and clean all the cars wax on wax off
and then the next day he comes back and
then he says sand the deck and then he
comes back and he says paint the fence
front and back and the kid just snaps
and he said I asked you to train me for
Cor karate when do we start training
karate and the old man starts throwing
punches and
kicks and he didn't realize that these
things I was doing it is the magic right
and that's one of the great frustrations
for folks is how
boring a whole well life can be and so
listening to you right
now gives me so much Joy because you
actually are doing all this crap it's
boring to go for yet another walk all
right what else man after this call we
are headed to my parents' house I want
to have that relationship with them and
I want to break through and how can
I start to have
this lifechanging moment and I feel like
I I to have some new deloney tools or
have a new self sense of self and I I
I've never been in this environment yet
so I'll leave it kind of open-ended
you have probably had imaginary
conversations where you finally just
tell them and you drop the mic drop
thing like oh and he goes ooh or you
have this this Goodwill Hunting moment
he starts crying and you all hug and you
all have this great
bond that almost never ever ever happens
in reality the greatest gift you can
give your family this weekend is a calm
non-anxious presence not a bunch of
answers I think it's you looking at your
old man
saying you did good and I got a lot of
work to do on my own but you did good
thank you and leave that
house leave that house with peace I hope
we don't cut this part cuz this is going
to be magic for people listening to this
because now you're heading out into the
wild right you are the Kate kid you're
actually going to the first tournament
and right before he goes into the fight
Mr Miyagi leans over and says Daniel
this is not a tournament this is for
real this is game on and that's where
you are headed right now 60 days in
okay hey guys video Journal day after
60-day checkin with deloney been crying
I've been sweating uh so I was able to
have a brief conversation with my
parents last night it was the first time
ever having to confront and say hey I
think you have really good intentions
but how it's coming across and how it's
landing on me in the specific word
you're using have really been really
hurtful for me and I want to connect
with you I want to heal with you it
didn't go the way I wanted it to and I
want to say the worst way possible cuz
again this is me being really it
just one of the hardest conversations
I've ever had in my entire life when I
got into the Motions of my usual 30
minute walk of processing the floodgates
open and I was able to process and
so I just want to say thank you and the
these steps really do work and at least
for me and they made a really big impact
it took going through something
completely new per se that I didn't
expect new pain and new hurt to actually
realize that you've been giving me tools
this entire time but I just feel like
I'm waking up
today completely different and really
excited to really walk out these tools
in this
[Music]
program
so like we talked um the last time we
talked and it was like all right so
you're going to write a letter you're
going to do this you're going to like
hug your dad to say you did a great job
what did you do it was she and I my mom
and my dad just just recapping like how
is this whole thing like going and
through this process I was like I feel
so confident about calmly like speaking
the truth calmly sharing my experience
that I think I
probably it was my first time out right
it was like it was like being a kid at
16 it's like your first time to drive
the car I'm going to go fast like we're
going to do this it was all not
intentional have you ever been on a
roller coaster like without the
strap very
similar and I spiraled that night like
it was that reoccurring in her voice of
see what happens when you speak up like
you know it's all your fault you threw
the you're sparring you threw the first
shot now you're in it there's no get out
so we ended up having a second
conversation tell me about that so what
so you chose to go back in if I'm you in
old old me I'm out but you chose to go
back in tell me about that so the next
day we were going to leave to come back
they just said hey did you still want to
talk to us and I said yeah so we we all
kind of sat down in a room like she and
I and both my parents and they said hey
we want to commit to
working through this whatever that looks
like yeah that's huge huh 90 days in
three months
later tell me about
Eric I I really realized through that
experience how much I had changed I went
from being a skeptic of like have I
really changed or these steps really
doing thing to be like whoa you may not
know that or experienced that like he
hasn't really changed but my internal
world has been flipped through that
self-healing process
[Music]
steps I feel like I lied to myself and I
didn't really believe I had a choice
that this was just the way I was going
to be the way it was yeah like this I
made some mistakes that I suffered
abused alcohol like this is always going
to follow me forever and I've lived in
the extremes that was the biggest thing
that helped me of like you realize this
is a journey and it's not going to take
you're not going to be to hit this in
this one moment of extreme
reaction whatever of like it's okay like
it takes time this is 90 days going on
9,000 or whatever the rest of my life is
cuz these steps like truly change my
life the gift you've given men who
aren't bad guys but who grew up
believing that they really were somehow
broken they were unlovable they had done
a thing that they couldn't come back
from you've given them a picture of what
it can look like and I need you to
know that that is Legacy changing stuff
that's how people change their family
tree and thank you for being on the ride
very difficult for somebody to be well
in isolation you can't get well by
yourself cuz yall are in it together and
so thank you for being on that ride and
also I get a less anxious more happy
more full husband cuz I'm getting to see
this journey and this progress like
sometimes from the sidelines sometimes
like in the middle of processes it's the
very first question you asked me
how do I forgive
myself has Eric forgiven
Eric did Eric even need to forgive Eric
I think I absolutely did need to forgive
myself forgive yourself for
what forgive myself for hating
myself there you
[Music]
go